here's a cloud tip for folks looking to
get a job in Cloud engineering when
applying for jobs candidates typically
need two things for most standard online
job applications a cover letter and a
resume so I asked Google bard what would
a good example resume be for a cloud
engineer as well as what is a good
example cover letter for a senior Cloud
engineer and the examples were specific
helpful and I was even able to specify
the engineering level as well as include
my full name in the template results
I've spent hours mentoring folks on
cover letter writing and writing my own
cover letters over the last six plus
years and this is going to save folks so
much time with their job search have you
tried using AI to help with your job
search let us know how you're using Bard
in the comments or check out the link in
our description to try out Bard for
yourself